[موسيقى]
اختارت بيجين ان توافق مبادرتها لانهاء
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ذكرى مرور سنه
على هذه الحرب
تقدم الصين نفسها طرفا محايدا يمكنه ان
يلعب دور الوسيط وتبني مبادرتها على اربعه
اسس احترام سياده الدول والابتعاد عن
عقليه الحرب البارده وانهاء القتال
واستئناف والحوار في الغرب استقبلت مبادره
الصين ببرود وبدا ان الرئيس الفرنسي هو
الاستثناء
كل ما يحقق السلام جيد ولكن يجب ان يمر
هذا السلام عبر توقف العدوان الروسي
وانسحاب القوات واحترام سياده اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان الخراط الصين في جهود السلام امر
جيد وساتوجه شخصيا الى الصين في بدايه
ابريل يجب ان تساعدنا الصين للضغط على
روسيا خصوصا فيما يتعلق باستخدام سلاحين
النووي والكيميائي
في المقابل قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انه لم يرى جديدا في هذه المبادره وانه
ليس هناك ما يؤشر الى وجود مستفيد من هذه
الحرب سوى روسيا واوضح ان فكره ان الصين
ستتفاوض على نتيجه حرب غير عادله تماما
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي فكره غير عقلانيه
وفق تعبيره موقف بايدن من المبادره
الصينيه كان متوقعا فادارته تقول ان الصين
تدرس مد روسيا بالسلاح لدعم حربها في
اوكرانيا الطرفان المعنيان مباشره
بالمبادره الصينيه استقبلاها بصيغه هذا
جيد ولكن
لا اعتقد انه مخطط سلام صيني لا يتعلق
الامر بتوصيه او اعلان لا يشكل ما اعلنته
الصين شيئا يمكن البناء عليه اعتقد ان
الصين كشفت عن افكارها الصين بدات تتحدث
عن اوكرانيا وهذا جيد جدا
ان الاهم هي الافعال التي ستتبع اقوال
الصين وا عزمه لقاء نظيره الصيني اما
موسكو فقد قالت انها تثمن عاليا الرغبه
الصادقه للاصدقاء في الصين لانهاء الصراع
في اوكرانيا لكن اي حل يجب ان يعترف
بالاوضاع الجديده على الارض تشير الخارجيه
الروسيه هنا لضم موسكو اربعه اقاليم
اوكرانيه وهذا ما يتناقض مع احد اسس
المبادره الصينيه وهو سياده الدول في
اجتماعات وزراء ماليه دول العشرين انضمت
الصين الى جانب روسيا دون باقي الاعضاء في
رفض الفقرتين المتعلقتين بالحرب في
اوكرانيا رغم انهما لا تحملان اي اتهام
مباشر لموسكو ويدفع هذا الدعم الدبلوماسي
الصيني لروسيا في الامم المتحده وخارجها
الدول الغربيه الى النظريه لبيجين كحليف
لموسكو في حربها ولذلك يشككون في مبادرتها
للسلام